[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I'm happy
to introduce today
Brian Olson, a former member
of this office from a few years
ago, who's been doing computer
science for many, many years
and also been
interested in applying
computer science to politics.
So he's here today to
talk about his thoughts
on that, using computer science
to get better democracy.
So please welcome Brian Olson.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN OLSON: So
if you've ever had
the feeling that our democracy
is not entirely fair,
and sometimes the deck
is stacked, you're right.
In a lot of places,
we have democracy
that has been distorted
by the state legislature,
using their power to make sure
that their favorite candidate
wins.
In Florida in 2010, they
passed by ballot initiative
a new law to prevent that from
happening, but it didn't work.
This map that the Florida State
legislature drew was later
thrown out by court decision.
So that's what we
call gerrymandering.
Gerrymandering is the
distortion of districts,
representational districts,
toward some political end.
How does it work?
So let's say you've got
this hypothetical map that
has the 60-40 split in
its population favoring
the green people.
Now, if you cut that up
in a very simple way,
you get three districts
that the green people win,
and two districts that
the purple people win,
preserving that ratio.
If you cut it differently, and
you pack enough green people
into just a couple
of districts, you
can get three districts where
the purple minority wins,
thus inverting and
letting the minority power
have the majority power in that
five-person state legislature.
Or if you do it the other way,
and you split the purple people
just right, they don't
get a majority anywhere,
and they're completely shut out.
These strategies of
"packing and cracking"
have been used in many
places around our country.
In Florida, this
district was found
to be illegally
packing too many people
of an under-represented
group into one district
so that they would have
less influence elsewhere.
Florida was doing that in 2012.
But this is gerrymandering from
1812 here in Massachusetts,
where the term was invented.
Governor Elbridge
Gerry signed into law
this map that was drawn
into political cartoon
as this monstrous
dragon, a salamander--
thus coining the "gerrymander."
It's gotten a lot worse lately,
because computers have allowed
people to draw lines
very finely, looking
at all the demographics
down to little pockets
of hundred people
here and there,
and thus making
designer districts just
for their particular purpose.
But what if we used that
same computational power
to make completely
impartial districts that
just tried to make
local representation
without any political bias?
You might get
something like this.
This is a map that I made
with my open source software.
We started to be able
to make this kind of map
about 10 years ago,
when home computers got
fast enough to do this.
So following the 2010 census,
I downloaded all of the data,
ran my home computer
for six months,
and generated 137 maps for
all the states and state
legislatures, except
for a few where there
were bugs I'm still working on.
This is North Carolina.
North Carolina has been in a
constitutional crisis for years
now over their gerrymandering.
They have had three years in a
row there are maps thrown out
by court, and they had
to go back and fix them I
forget which generation
of the map it is.
This is probably
the map from 2013.
You can see this
big red district
reaching into and around three
other districts around it.
This pink district
pinches down as
narrow as possible
while reaching out
to grab other areas.
This is nuts.
And the court has
found that this
is nuts and illegal and
trying to distort the system.
It could be like this, though.
You can go from the
hallmarks of gerrymandering,
all of these fiddly
bits reaching
into and around everything,
to soap bubbles.
Maryland also has one of the
most distorted, contorted
district mappings
I've ever seen.
This is a Democratic
Party gerrymander
based on the Maryland
State legislature's
Democratic majority.
The previous two were
Republican gerrymanders.
Maryland's Republican
governor made some news
briefly calling out
for help, can somebody
please help fix my state?
To which President
Obama said, yeah,
we should fix gerrymandering
everywhere, please.
It could be like this.
So my point about
gerrymandering is that there
is technology possible.
There is political
will on both sides
of the aisle in various places
to want to make a saner system.
So let's do it.
So how did I do it?
I wrote effectively
a custom GIS stack--
Geographic Information Systems.
It was a lot of code
and various tools,
depending on what part
I was going to do.
But it's pretty efficient.
It runs on home computers.
It's open source.
You can all go look at it, but
you probably wouldn't want to.
It's not very pretty code,
but I'm working on that.
And I'm going to update it
again for the 2020 cycle.
It does that kind of
data pre-processing stuff
you'd expect, because it
downloads raw census data,
turns it into just the data
needed to do redistricting,
solves that.
It can run in a distributed
fashion on as many computers
as you throw at it.
And then finally
rendering the map output.
What data do you actually
need to run this?
The census data provides
blocks as the lowest
level of information they have.
Sometimes literally
a city block,
sometimes just miles and
miles and acres and acres
of land in Montana between
this stream and that stream.
But blocks that are
blatantly split up
based on some political
or physical boundary.
And the whole
country is split up
into about 9 and 1/2
million blocks of data.
Some blocks have just 100
people or zero people.
Some blocks have 1,000 people.
Each of those blocks
has a position.
It has its neighbors,
because districts
have to be contiguous.
They can't have part
of a district here
and part of a district here
with nothing in between.
Although sometimes a
gerrymandered district
will have a town over
here, a town over here,
and a thin strip
of road in between.
Land area and information.
So my process takes the
raw census data down from 2
and 1/2 gigabytes of raw data
down to about 16 megabytes
for a typical state
of what I actually
need to solve this problem.
Makes it much more tractable.
So what I'm actually solving for
in my definition of compactness
is the average
distance per person
to the center of their district.
If this little
map is a district,
and those are blocks with
population counts in them,
I find the center
of the district
and then measure the distance
to all of those blocks
and weight it by the population.
And minimizing for that score
is how I identify a locality.
A locality will be a relatively
high-density population area
surrounded by a more
sparse area around it
in a typical town,
city arrangement.
And that's all I'm
optimizing for.
Just compact localities, and
no political or demographic
information.
You can look at the demographic
information, though.
The census provides
lots of race-
and income-based demographics.
And one of the big questions
is, the Voting Rights
Act used to specify
that there would
be a certain kind of
gerrymandering for good.
There shall be,
in certain states,
a majority minority
district to make sure
you get a black congressman
from Georgia, for example.
And my system does not try to
make those, but in a few states
it winds up with them
anyway, just because of where
people are self-sorting into
where they choose to live.
So that's still an open question
about how we do this, though.
The details are a heuristic
hill-climbing search.
I can talk to you more about
that if you're really curious.
This is one run through the data
of getting a little bit better,
a little bit better, as
it's searching for a better
solution.
So that's the short, short
version of gerrymandering
and what you can do to
make an impartial map.
There's one other big fix that
I'd like to see in our system,
and that is when we actually
go to vote for people,
we can do better.
You should never, ever
again, if at all possible,
pick just one
person on a ballot.
You all know the problem
of being told, oh,
don't vote for them, you're
throwing your vote away.
It's a two-party system.
You have to vote for one of us.
But we can do better.
Once upon a time,
a mathematician
proved that if you only
have one choice, that's
only enough information to
pick between two choices.
If you only get to mark
one person on your ballot,
it will devolve to
a two-party system.
So let's do better.
Let's rank our choices, first,
second, third, and so on,
or rate them on some scale,
like a five-star scale,
or A through F letter
grading, or minus 10 to 10.
Or even just approve,
disapprove on each candidate
gives you better results
than picking one.
But this is just data.
If you can say something
about every candidate,
you're not throwing
your vote away.
You have said something
about every candidate.
You said, yes, I like
this one, and this one's
OK, and that one--
no, no, not them.
And if you don't
get your favorite,
you might get your
second favorite.
So you can vote for the weird,
obscure, idealistic candidate
who just really gets
you moving, and then you
can have your second choice,
yeah, popular, mediocre,
or whatever.
And then, if it's
just not your year,
and you don't get
any of them, you
can keep ranking
your vote on down,
and maybe you can help the other
party elect a moderate instead
of their crazy person.
So ranked choice voting is good.
But there are many algorithms
to count these ballots,
and they all have trade-offs.
There was a famous
theorem that proved
you can't have a perfect system
based on some set of qualities
that all sound good,
and it was proven
you can't have all of those
qualities at the same time.
But you can still have
a pretty good system.
You can still have a
better system, and maybe
a best system.
And our current system
is the worst system
aside from actual tyranny.
So here's one algorithm.
Instant runoff voting.
So you have a rankings ballot.
You count up all the
first choice votes.
If someone has a simple
majority, great, they win.
Otherwise, whoever has the
fewest first choice votes,
you disqualify them.
And all of those ballots, well,
let's count their second choice
vote now.
And this repeats, disqualifying
until finally somebody wins.
Very simple system.
It was used in
Burlington, Vermont,
for a couple mayoral elections.
And after you filter out
the lesser candidates,
here are just the dramatic
finish of that election, where
people are getting
disqualified one by one,
and then finally
you have a winner.
One thing you can
see about this is
the vote counts for the
eventual winners keep going up.
As Dan Smith's candidate's
votes are disqualified,
well, they had a second choice
of one of the other candidates.
So those counts go up.
As Andy Montroll
is disqualified,
the other counts go up as
those votes are transferred.
Another algorithm.
Condorcet method,
or Con-dor-say.
A French mathematician
from 100 years ago.
I like to think of this
as a virtual round robin
tournament, where the match
score between each candidate
is how many people
like A higher than B
versus how many people
like B higher than A.
And that's the score
of them, and if more
people like A higher than
B than like B more than A,
then A should win.
A has defeated B. A ranked vote
says, I like A higher than B,
and A higher than C,
and A higher than D,
and I also like B higher than C.
So you have
information about all
of these hypothetical pairings,
and you can count it up,
and the result looks
something like this.
This count says that
from the same Burlington,
Vermont election data--
they published the
full anonymized vote
set, which is really useful
for research like this.
This count says that 4,067
people liked Andy Montroll
better than Bob Kiss,
and 3,477 people
liked Bob Kiss better
than Andy Montroll.
And 4,500 people liked
Andy more than Kurt or Dan.
b is different.
This is a different outcome
than the instant runoff voting
election.
This is saying more
people like Andy Montroll
than Bob Kiss or Kurt Wright.
But the previous election was
that Bob Kiss wound up winning.
How did this happen?
Andy Montroll had a huge support
at the second choice level.
Kurt Wright and Bob Kiss had
really fanatic fans, but not
so many of them in the end.
So Andy Montroll might have
been the centrist candidate that
made a lot of
people pretty happy,
but he wasn't the first choice,
and instant runoff voting only
looks at the first choice,
whereas a virtual round robin
election looks at all
of the data at once.
So just from a perspective of
navigating the solution space,
Condorcet is a better algorithm.
And it requires exactly
the same inputs.
A rankings ballot, first,
second, third, and so on.
Instant runoff voting was
used in Burlington, Vermont
twice and then repealed,
because they wound up really
not liking the guy it
elected on the second try.
And they could have had
a different outcome.
The algorithm matters.
In this age of search
engines and news feeds,
the algorithm matters.
You have a big pile
of data, but then
what do you actually do with it?
And one more thing out
there is that if you're
picking more than
one person, there's
an even more powerful
thing you can do.
Proportional representation
is the notion
that if you're electing a city
council or a state legislature,
if 20% of the people show up
in some constituency and vote
for whatever their
favorite cause is, then
20% of the seats
of the legislature
should go to that
20% group of people.
That's proportional
representation.
And there's an algorithm called
single transferable vote, which
is used to achieve just
that in the Cambridge City
Council and a few
parliaments around the world,
like the Irish Senate.
And they're trying
it out in Australia.
And I think this is a really
powerful hack on democracy,
because what if you had a state
legislature that was not--
if it was 40 people, and it
wasn't 21 Democrats and 19
Republicans, it was 13
Democrats, 12 Republicans,
five Greens, three Libertarians,
and, I don't know, that guy.
That would be a much
more interesting
and vibrant and
representative democracy.
This is about representing us.
All of this is about
representing us,
whether we are people
who live in an area
and might have common concerns,
like, you live near Boston.
You probably want the T to run.
Or you live near Amherst.
You want-- well, I don't know
what they want in Amherst.
And that's part of the problem.
Or you can have the
ideological representation
of a proportional representation
system, where you get together
and say, we all really care
about preserving our parks
and open spaces
and green spaces.
And if 10% of the people
show up and vote for that,
then they are going to get a
couple of seats that are just
really going to push
for that and introduce
new legislation around that and
build coalitions around that.
So these are what I think
are the most important hacks
that we can do to
improve our continuing
democratic experiment.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions?
AUDIENCE: I was just curious
what your thoughts were
on approval voting, where
you choose which candidates
you like and which
you don't like,
and then whoever gets
the most acceptance wins.
Which is a little simplier
than some of the other systems,
but still usually gets
pretty good results,
from what I've seen.
BRIAN OLSON: Yes.
It is definitely simpler.
It definitely gives
pretty good results.
Another thing I've done
that I didn't show here
is run simulations on
millions of simulated voters.
It's a model.
It's maybe not the best model.
But it shows that, yes,
approval is pretty good.
I just find it
unsatisfying personally.
I want to say, I like this
guy better than this guy.
And so I would prefer a
rankings or a ratings ballot.
But yes, approval
is pretty good.
And if it's the matter of, if
you're just designing a survey
form, if you can just
switch from radio buttons
to checkboxes, that's all you
need to do to get better data.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Brian.
Thank you.
First of all, I
wanted to say that I'm
on the board of an organization
called Voter Choice
Massachusetts, where we're
advancing ranked choice
voting here in Massachusetts.
And I have a sign-up sheet,
if anybody wants to sign up.
We have legislation
and other things.
I do want to
respond a little bit
to the criticism of the
instant runoff algorithm.
You bring up Burlington,
and Burlington's not
the only city that's used it.
Currently, 11 cities
in the United States
use that form of
ranked choice voting.
And there's been over
150 elections since 2004
using that version.
The Burlington 2009
election is the only one
where the instant runoff result
has differed from the Condorcet
result. So in practice,
it seems to be
a very, very rare outcome.
So that's one comment
I wanted to make.
And the other thing is that
I'm a little bit concerned
with the Condorcet
algorithm about some
of the strategic manipulations
that it is vulnerable to.
For example, two front-runners.
If you insincerely rank your
formidable opponent last,
that can benefit you.
Or bullet voting
your first choice
and not deciding to rank
the rest of the choices
can benefit that first
choice, can benefit
that favorite candidate.
And those are certain
strategic vulnerabilities
that the instant runoff
version is immune to,
and I think that's
part of the reason it's
been successful in being
implemented across the country.
And most recently, Maine became
the first state in the nation
to enact it--
historic first state nation to
enact it for statewide offices.
So that's my commentary on this.
BRIAN OLSON: I look forward
to the Maine experiment.
I wish them well.
I hope they release
full data so that we
can analyze it properly.
And yes, it's true that most
of the time instant runoff
voting and Condorcet agree.
My argument is that
for no additional cost,
you can get a better choice
when they don't agree.
The strategic concerns?
There's what is sometimes called
the favorite betrayal problem
of, you have your favorite, and
so you really want them to win,
so you vote for them first.
And then you vote for
your second favorite,
but if it hadn't been for that
vote for that second favorite,
your favorite would have won.
And instant runoff
voting doesn't do that,
because it doesn't look
at your second favorite.
But I think that's a flawed
analysis, because it's not just
all about you.
It's also about what
can we all agree on.
Your second choice is
also pretty good, I hope.
And so if you say, well,
this is pretty good,
and it makes the rest
of the group also happy,
that should be an OK outcome.
And if you are voting
dishonestly and saying,
yes, I want Hillary
first and Bernie last,
then you are shooting
yourself in the foot.
Don't do that.
Please don't do that.
Please just vote honestly
and say I like Hillary first
and Bernie second, or I like
Bernie first and Hillary
second, or I like Winona
LaDuke first and whatever else,
and then Hillary
and then Bernie.
Just vote honestly, and if
we implement a good system,
it will do the right thing
with that honest vote.
So that's what I would
say, is vote honestly.
If you don't get
your first choice,
you might get your
second choice,
and that should
still be pretty good.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about policy.
I forgot about Maine, and I'm
really excited that Maine is
moving to ranked choice voting.
But in general, with both
gerrymandering and things
like ranked choice
voting, I notice
that generally the
people in charge
of making the change
to better systems
are the people in
power, who probably
stand to benefit the least.
If you want to keep control
of the two-party system
because it works
fairly well for you
and it works fairly well for
Democrats and Republicans,
you probably aren't
excited to hear
about these exciting
new plans to help
get third-party candidates or
vote for multiple candidates,
rather than being forced to pick
between the two major parties.
So I was wondering if
you could speak to--
in spite of that,
what I perceive
as an obstacle,
what people can do
to keep this conversation going
and keep progress growing.
BRIAN OLSON: Right.
Getting it through the
traditional legislative process
is--
there is an obvious
conflict of interest
between people who won via
the old system versus enacting
a new system.
And so I believe that most
of the time it gets in,
it gets in via
ballot initiative.
Direct democracy.
People put something on
the ballot, they vote it,
it becomes law.
That's what happened in Maine
and several other places.
Even in the Burlington
City Council.
The Burlington
mayoral election was
something that was
voted on, a proposition
that was locally voted on
directly by the people,
in and out.
AUDIENCE: This is kind of a
similar comment or question,
but with gerrymandering
in particular,
I think as you
mentioned, there's
a lot of incentive for
people to keep doing it.
And I can see relinquishing
all the control to a computer
might be hard, or an algorithm.
What are your
thoughts on proposals
of just limiting
the amount of damage
that gerrymandering can do?
One thing that I've
seen or suggested
is, you've got n
districts, you can
draw n minus 1 straight
line segments on the map,
or some other--
because right now,
like you say, there's
just contiguousness of a space.
But you could have some
aspect ratio or something
like that that constrains
the problem such
that there is
still some control,
but hopefully not as ridiculous
as some of these maps
you've shown.
BRIAN OLSON: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
One of the ways that this
is going through my work
and through others is
computational accountability
of gerrymandering.
There was recent
work out of Illinois
where they just simulated
hundreds of thousands
of plausible maps and then
analyzed the current map
and saying, is this
outcome likely,
or is this outcome
unlikely, and therefore
evidence of malfeasance.
So that's an
interesting approach.
So in passing laws
one state at a time,
there's a unilateral
disarmament problem,
where if a blue state
gives up its gerrymander,
and a red state keeps
its gerrymander, then
the Congress is distorted.
So we need something that
can be applied everywhere.
And in that strategic
vein, I know one person
who's advocating computational
accountability and court
challenges, because
the ACLU and the League
of Women Voters and
Common Cause can
go into a state that
has gerrymandered
and sue them to get
it un-gerrymandered.
And you can apply a
national lawyering dollars
to fix a local problem.
And there's a certain
logic to that strategy.
Also, giving up the pen entirely
and letting a computer do it
fully automatically,
obviously we'll
have missed some opportunities
that a good person looking
at a map would do.
Someone who really
understands Massachusetts
could draw lines to say, oh,
these people go together,
because reasons.
This is actually a
community of interest.
These people will actually
identify together.
But the problem is, we have very
few of those people actually
drawing lines.
I believe Iowa has had a pretty
good independent commission
model for redistricting
for several decades,
and it's worked pretty well.
They also only have
four congresspeople,
so there's not a whole lot
of wiggle room to play with.
But versus Alaska,
at last I checked,
their state
legislature maps have
been subject to court challenge
every decade since statehood.
AUDIENCE: I had a quick
comment about strategic voting,
because it came up.
So everyone mentioned that
for no single member district
is it--
there's no voting system
that completely eliminates
strategic voting, even
in instant runoff,
because of that situation
where who your first choice is
matters, in terms of whether
a candidate who was otherwise
widely acceptable can get
eliminated in the first round.
There is some incentive
to strategically vote
for who your first
choice is, even
with instant runoff voting.
There's analysis I saw
which showed ratings,
or approval voting
does have less ability
to vote strategically,
and certainly even
instant runoff voting still is
much lower than single-member.
But I believe from
what I've read,
if you have multi-member
districts, that largely gets
[INAUDIBLE] strategic voting.
So I wasn't sure if you
had thoughts on that.
BRIAN OLSON: Yeah.
That gets into proportional
representation.
So if you're electing five
or more people at once,
then you want to vote
for who you really want,
and you're more
likely to get them,
because you will be voting
as part of some coalition,
most likely.
You will be voting with the
Dems or Greens or Libertarians
or Republicans or the Nature
Conservancy or the gun lobby.
You will be voting with
some group on the issue,
and so you will get
something, most likely,
in a proportional
representation scheme.
So it's a pressure release
valve for the pressure
of electing one person.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the
talk and for all the work
you're doing.
So I have a point, and then
a comment and a question,
I guess.
So my comment is, you'd
mentioned just earlier,
in response to one of
your earlier questions
about how voters shouldn't
try to game the system,
for instance, depending
on the algorithm being
used for ranked choice voting.
Vote for your
sincere intentions,
not some strategized,
clever hacking
of that, of whatever the
specific algorithm is.
So I guess the issue
that I have in general,
having followed
politics for a while
and been very frustrated with
how dysfunctional government
and electoral processes are and
all that, and the unfairness
or bias in the system, and the
gaming of the system and so
on, is that it seems like
underneath it all, this very
human, subjective problem.
And at the other
end of the spectrum
is objective ways of approaching
it, like you're framing here.
Just have an algorithm, which
is blind to these various
subjective factors.
But then at the end of
the day, as you point out,
voters and politicians are going
to know about the underlying
objective system, and if
their mindset is diabolical,
they're going to find ways
of subverting the system.
Which maybe speaks
to, well, some systems
are just more difficult
to game than others.
But humans are very
clever, and we're always
going to find ways, if we have
bad intentions, of undermining
the system or getting our
result even if it's not really
borne out in the majority of
the population, for instance.
So this is just a
commentary about,
even with all these objective
measures, there's always
going to be that desire, if
there's kind of bad intentions
out there.
So this gets me
thinking about, how
do we actually minimize the
impact of those bad intentions
by promoting healthier mindsets
toward our self-governance
and things like that?
It isn't diametrically
opposed to what you're doing.
There is a relation there.
If you want to speak to
that, that'd be great.
But also, my
follow-up question is,
have you looked into producing
egregious examples of--
if you turned your
algorithm evil,
how bad can you make it to
perhaps maybe shine a light on,
this is how bad the situation--
if you wanted to really
be strategic about undermining
democratic principles
and majority government and
minority representation, here's
how you could do it,
and this is how awful
and how distasteful
it would be, if you
were better at trying to
gerrymander than you currently
are?
Might that help people shine a
light on how bad it could be?
BRIAN OLSON: So to answer
your second point first,
the data that I
would want for that
would be recent
precinct-by-precinct election
data for a general election.
A governor, a
senator, a president.
And then I would map those
precinct data back out
onto the world and
say, OK, how do
I cut this up so that I
get the most of my party
winning and the fewest of
the other party winning?
And the problem is, that data
is really hard to come by.
It's different state-by-state.
Sometimes it's different
county-by-county.
They don't just hand it
out, except to the parties.
I was very familiar with the
law when I lived in California.
The parties just get that data.
If you are a major
party in California,
you get a copy of the
address of every registered
voter in the state.
You've been talking to the
elections officials, the county
clerk and whatnot, for decades.
And you can just
show up and say, hey,
can I have a data dump
from last Tuesday?
And they're like,
yeah, all right.
There is a very small,
nascent distributed network
of people trying to
gather that data,
and they have a handful of
states for a handful of years.
And it's just hard to come by.
AUDIENCE: That's just an issue
of just getting enough people
aggregating all this data from
all the different districts?
BRIAN OLSON: Yeah.
Back on the first choice
around psychology and voting,
it is my sincere hope
that a better system
will open up people to thinking
about the system differently.
You know right now that
if you vote for Nader,
he's not going to win.
But sometimes you do
anyway, because you
hope it sends a
message, or you're just
being idealistic or whatever.
And I kind of applaud
that idealism.
I just want to say, OK, but
do you have a second choice?
And that would
improve the outcome.
Or, OK, you really
like Trump, but do
you have a second choice?
What could have happened in the
most recent Republican primary
if you had it sorted
out differently?
And because there were
15 different candidates
at some point that
were considered viable
at some level, that could have
gone in any which direction.
And speaking of could
have gone in any which
direction, the French
presidential election.
This year less so,
but back in 2002,
they had a very close election.
The first round election
had people coming
in at 23%, 21%, 15%, 13%, 10%.
And this is in a
pick one ballot.
But all those people who
voted for the top two,
then they had a top two runoff.
And the second choice candidate
was the elder Monsieur Le
Pen, who got 20% in
the first round and 20%
in the second round,
because he was out there
and he had his die-hard
followers and nobody else.
And everyone else
said, OK, I guess
we vote for the boring guy.
AUDIENCE: And I wonder with--
if that was the new
established system,
if given current
hyper-partisan, very tribal,
divided electorate, that
even in the primaries
it gets kind of micro-tribal,
where given that environment,
it would just descend
into, OK, in the primaries,
vote Trump first, Cruz last,
or Hillary first, Bernie last.
Make up for that--
you want to recover
that kind of tribal--
BRIAN OLSON: Right.
AUDIENCE: You can do that.
SPEAKER: I hope not.
And I hope that having
these things actually run
and looking at actual
data will bear out
that, yeah, probably a
few people will do that,
but if you're sending a message,
you should send a message of,
this is what I really
like, and this will do,
and this is not so bad,
this is really bad.
Just actually send that message.
And if we have a good
election algorithm,
a good result will come out.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
A question about your
redistricting algorithm.
Why did you choose average
distance to the center
as the thing to maximize for?
Are there other options?
What other types of
things did you look at?
BRIAN OLSON: Sure.
There are dozens of proposed
measures of what is generally
called compactness.
The opposite of compactness
is the sprawling tendrils
of tentacled monster districts.
So there are lots
of ways of measuring
what a compact district is.
A lot of them are
purely geometrical.
The length of the perimeter
around the district.
The ratio of the area of
the district to the area
of the smallest enclosing
circle of the district.
And these kinds of things.
But what these purely
geometrical measures don't do
is, they don't tell you
anything about the distribution
of the people
inside the district.
So imagine, if you will, a
perfectly circular district.
This is perfectly compact.
What if it is
perfectly circular,
but there is a huge
city off on one edge,
and then rural
areas out from it?
That is perhaps not the ideal
of having a perfectly circular
district that is just
a bull's eye on a city,
that it's representing
that city and metro area.
So that's what I
wanted to do, is
by measuring the
distribution of the people,
how far away are the people from
the center of their district?
How tightly packed
are the people?
So that's what I really
wanted to measure
in designing my measure.
There are still some variations.
I'm still looking
into other things.
One thing I'm doing is
I'm measuring the land
area of the district and finding
the center of the land area,
and measuring the
distance to people.
Maybe I should just completely
forget about land entirely
and measure the population
center of the district,
and measure the distance
from people to people.
And on even-numbered
days, I believe in one,
and odd numbers the other.
But I implemented this one,
and I think it's pretty good.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I think
to some extent,
you need to consider natural
boundaries and transportation
and things like that.
But that wasn't what I was
going to comment about.
At the end of your
prepared remarks--
I think you briefly
touched on this--
I found it dissatisfying
that states
with bicameral legislatures
have two bodies, each
of whose members are allocated
based on arbitrary geographic
boundaries.
And I was wondering
why they don't just
make one of the bodies
at- large seating
with preferential balloting
or something like that.
BRIAN OLSON: Yes,
I would love that.
For every bicameral legislature,
take the smaller one
and maybe run it in
two off-cycle sessions.
If you have a state
legislature of 40 people
with four-year terms,
run it in two sessions,
so you're electing 20
people every two years
at large across the whole state.
Proportional representation.
I would love that.
If anyone wants to write up
a constitutional amendment
for a state, let's do it.
AUDIENCE: So I
have two questions.
The first was, you
had mentioned things
about partial representation
or transferable vote.
And the US system
is traditionally
very much region-oriented
electoral process.
And I guess the first
question is, how do you
balance these two objectives?
BRIAN OLSON:
Basically, in spending
15 years studying districting,
the most unexpected thing
that I discovered is that people
don't actually want districts.
They don't actually care
about local representation
nearly as much as they do about
ideological representation.
I mean, that is
especially true in
the current political climate.
There are times when
having a local rep
is still awfully
handy, and people
will identify with a local
representative, which
is why in a bicameral system,
I would have one of each.
I would have a districted
local representative
and the at-large proportional
ideological representative.
And there's a current
court case in Wisconsin
that I think is sitting
with SCOTUS right now that
is putting this to the
test of, will Wisconsin
be required to gerrymander
for both parties?
Will it be required to achieve
proportional representation
by district, saying, OK,
this state is 60% Republican
and 40% Democrat.
We should make sure that our
state legislature and our US
House seats break
in the same way,
even if that means that 49%
of people in every district
are unhappy?
Whereas if you had a
proportional system,
you're not in a district,
and you might still
have some representative
that you feel affinity for?
So yeah, I see people trying
to achieve proportionality
through districting,
and I find that to be
a terribly awkward fit.
And I think what
they actually want
is a more direct proportional
system, if we could just
figure out a way to
broach the subject
and start down that reform path.
AUDIENCE: The second question
I had is a little bit
orthogonal to the talk.
But it used to be that
the Senate and the US
elected representatives were
elected by state legislatures,
rather than directly
from the people.
And this, I think, was
viewed as a mechanism
to squash short-term passions.
My question is, what do you
think about these tiered voting
systems?
BRIAN OLSON: There is
definitely a rationale
for a hierarchical system,
where each layer elects
the layer above it.
You get network effects.
Every layer has its own--
what's that guy?
The number, 150-- so if there's
only so many relationships
that you can carry
on as a human, then
every layer mimics
that star topology.
And I think that can make sense.
Direct democracy has its place.
So let's take the president.
Right now, we have a
fake direct election
And every four years,
this frustrates me,
and I wish we had either
a real direct election
with an actual
national popular vote,
or we would quit
faking it and just
let the state
legislature decide,
and we would have more of
a parliamentary system.
And we have this one
national vote that
can get thrown out sometimes?
What's up with that?
So I think we should either
have real hierarchical systems
or real direct systems.
And there's a place for each.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: On your
redistricting algorithm,
you talked a lot
about compactness
was there anything about
trying to keep the districts
of near-equal population?
BRIAN OLSON: Oh, yeah.
They are all with
equal population
to within half a percent.
Current maps sometimes
get it down to exactly 1%,
and they're doing funny
business to achieve that.
So I didn't bother keeping
myself to that strategy.
So I'm just keeping it
to within half a percent
variance between districts.
The traditional
requirements of districts
are equal population and
contiguous, and that's it.
And at various court
decisions, they
refused to put any other
restrictions on it,
and therefore the
state legislature
does whatever partisan
hackery they want.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
There's recently some news
coverage about research
into a partisan efficiency gap.
Have you been following
that, and do you
have hope that that might
help swing districts away
from gerrymandering?
BRIAN OLSON: Yeah.
This came up again about
the recent Wisconsin case.
And it is following that
line of logic I believe
leads to shoddy proportionality
through districting where
we say, we will make
the districts such
that this 60-40 state turns out
with 60-40 end representatives,
which in some ways
would be an improvement
over the current system where
you have a 48-52% state that
winds up being a 60-40
representation because
of gerrymandering, really
pushing it that extra gap.
So in the balance of
power way, it's better.
But in terms of actually
representing people,
I'm not sure.
AUDIENCE: This is a little
bit of an out-there question,
but have you looked at using
your redistricting algorithm,
or a redistricting
algorithm, for things
other than districts?
Like the states, or the
Balkans, or other places
that have somewhat
arbitrary lines.
What does that look like?
BRIAN OLSON: It's
on my to-do list of,
well, what if we
redistricted the Senate?
Because the US
Senate is nonsensical
in its current implementation.
I believe it made
sense in 1790, when
the states had an
option of being actually
independent mini-nationalities.
We could have Rhode Island
hanging out with Luxembourg,
and they'd be on equal footing.
But I don't think it
makes sense anymore.
I would love to see
the US Senate replaced
with an at-large
proportional body
with 33 people elected
every two years.
That would be
really interesting,
to have a national
Senate election.
But we should probably
try it on a state level
first, because the states are
the laboratories of democracy.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
AUDIENCE: In your packing
and cracking slides,
you showed how to
push a 60/40 populace
to one end or the other.
Do you have measurements on
how your system approximates
representational voting in all
the states and other algorithms
as well?
BRIAN OLSON: That
goes back to, I
would need to get the partisan
election data in order
to do that kind of modeling.
So I have the census's
built-in racial demographics
for my districts.
So I can tell you, yes, I make
two majority black districts
in Georgia.
But as for party breakdown,
I don't have that data.
AUDIENCE: So
another ramification
of gerrymandering-- by
creating safe seats, you end up
getting more radical or
extreme people elected
than reflects the population
as a whole, as we've seen.
So while getting closer
to proportionality
through districting may seem
unsatisfactory at some level,
it would also have the effect
of a different population
of elected representatives,
a much more representative
and a moderate one.
So that seems like a
highly desirable outcome.
I think coupled with probably
the most pragmatic solution
to these gerrymandering problems
is the judicial solution,
and the fact that big data
does allow us to actually
score these gerrymandering
districts now,
and to impose requirements that
districting schemes do obey
some computational fairness,
which not only gets us closer--
yes, less perfectly
satisfactory, but closer
to representational, and
therefore more elected
representatives.
That seems like a
double goodness.
How does that strike you?
BRIAN OLSON: Yeah.
We definitely have a
problem with safe seats.
I worked a campaign when
I lived in California.
I was briefly the
volunteer webmaster
for a congressional
campaign for a few months.
Let me say that again.
I was the volunteer webmaster
for a congressional campaign.
Because they were
running in a district
that was gerrymandered
against them.
For many years, California
had a bipartisan gerrymander,
where everybody on both
sides had a safe seat.
And so our party did
not send any help.
They figured we
were a lost cause.
And their candidate
would not even
agree to show up
for any debates.
They did not deign to partake
in the democratic process,
because they didn't have to.
They had a safe seat.
And there are lots of
sociological analysis
to be done in saying, oh, all
these safe seat politicians
are now more extremist,
because some of them
have had primary challenges
from the extreme wing
of their party.
And those are the most motivated
people who actually get out
during a primary.
So we're representing
2% of the people.
2% of the people show
up, vote in a primary,
and that's who wins.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that hierarchical voting
schemes and direct democracy
each had their place.
I wondered if you could
say a little bit more
about which places are more
appropriate for which method.
BRIAN OLSON: Well, maybe this is
part of the checks and balances
system of our government.
We have a state legislature
that is elected from pretty
small local districts.
In Massachusetts, some of our
districts are 30,000-something
people.
And then we also have a governor
who is voted on by everyone.
So you have that
play right there.
You have the direct
democracy of,
everyone votes and gets one
representative for everyone,
and everyone votes and gets
their local representative,
who work together in the
milieu of the state House
to do their thing.
And I don't think
we would ever be
happy with a fully hierarchical
system, because we would then
lose touch with people
a few levels up,
and we would see them doing
things, and we would say,
ah, they don't represent us.
AUDIENCE: So what you're
saying is you want a mix.
BRIAN OLSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: For these things,
you want this reason.
You want some of each.
BRIAN OLSON: Yes.
[APPLAUSE]